what i want to do in this video is focus
a little bit more on the results of the
last video and make sure that they make
intuitive and mathematical sense to us
because something slightly strange
happened we had a linear demand curve
right over here which means for any
given change in price right over here so
in all of the examples whether we went
from a to b or c to d or e to f we had a
one dollar drop in price we had a one
dollar drop in price
one dollar drop in price and every time
we had a one dollar drop in price we had
a two dollar increase or sorry we had a
two unit increase in quantity demanded
so we had a two unit increase in
quantity demanded this is a linear
demand curve but despite the fact that
for each you for for each dollar drop in
price we had the same increase in
quantity demanded the slightly maybe
unintuitive thing that happened was we
we had a slight we had a different and
actually a very different elasticity of
demand
and you might imagine that probably has
something to do with the fact that
elasticity of demand is based on
percentage change in quantity relative
to percentage change in price instead of
just change in quantity over change in
price if it was just changing quantity
over change in price we would get
something we would be constant but we
saw very very different results and when
you look closely at these so let's focus
on this region between a and b right
over here
we had a one dollar change in price or
one dollar change in price was on a
relatively large base our price was
already high remember we use we use to
figure out the percent change we use a
dollar over the average the average of
our two points so we don't do a dollar
over nine because then we would have a
different elasticity when we went from a
to b then when we went from b to a a
dollar over nine versus a dollar over
eight or would give you two different
percentages instead we say a dollar over
eight and a half so this price percent
change was in the teens while this
quantity percent change is going to be
was 67
2 over 2 over an average quantity of 3
in this region right over here so you
had a relatively large actually quite
large percent change in quantity over a
relatively small percent change in price
67 over something that's in may roughly
in the mid teens percentage and so
that's why the absolute value of our
elasticity of demand was a relatively
large number if you don't think about
the absolute value you get a negative
number because this is the downward this
is a downwards sloping line but if you
focus on the absolute value it's a the
magnitude of it is a relatively large
number relatively large percent change
in quantity relative to your percent
change in price and it all comes out of
your quantities are low here so if you
move two on a low base you're going to
have a large percentage change in
quantity and your prices are relatively
high here so a change in one isn't going
to be that large of a percentage but
when you have
the your when your absolute value over
your elasticity of demand is greater
than one like it is right over here so
when your absolute value of your
elasticity of demand is greater than one
it's usually called this point in the
curve is elastic or generally elastic so
this is elastic
elastic you get some nice percentage
movements in quantity for given change
percentage change in price
then when you go over here our prices
have gone our price is done is lower
when we're in this region between c and
d so that dollar difference is going to
be a larger percentage change in price
and our quantities are higher so that
two dollar change is going to be a lower
change in quantity and actually they end
up being the same thing because you have
a dollar change in price over an average
base of five right the average between
550 and 450 is five so you have a 20
change in price a 20 drop in price
and you have a 20
increase in quantity
increase in quantity so let me write
this is in the teens over here
my writing is getting too small so i
won't do that so you have a 20 change in
price and a 20 increase in quantity is
20 because you have 2 over the average
year 2 over 10. so 20 increase so that's
why your elasticity of demand or the
magnitude of your elasticity of demand
is exactly one and if you if your
magnitude of your elasticity demand is
exactly one we say that you have unit
elasticity at that point elasticity
and then finally if you go all the way
down here our prices end up being quite
low
our prices are quite low so a dollar
change is actually a huge percentage
price change right our base year is our
average base here is a dollar fifty in
this region right over here and so a
dollar over a dollar fifty it's a huge
it's a huge it's actually a it's a it's
a sixty it's a sixty seven percent
change in price sixty-seven yeah that's
right yeah one dollar it's a two-thirds
change in price it's a huge percent
change in price but once again now our
quantity is much larger so two dollar
increase isn't that large of a change in
quantity so you have a smaller percent
change in quantity over a large percent
change in price so that means that
you're relatively inelastic you're not
getting you're not getting a lot of
change in quantity for the the magnitude
of your change in price and so if you're
if the magnitude of the elasticity of
demand is less than one over here we
call that either relatively inelastic or
just inelastic
in
elastic so i'll leave you there in this
video just i want you to really kind of
internalize what we're doing here
especially with the math and especially
understanding why the elasticities
change here get you thinking in terms of
percentages and also make you hopefully
you appreciate why we're taking the
average of these two points when we find
the denominator for the percentages
instead of just taking one of the two
points so that we get the same
elasticity of demand either direction we
go in